the quest to be respected is the most
natural
thing in the world for human beings we
are designed by natural selection
to want people to think highly of us but
we weren't designed
to live in this environment where
we are every day seeing how much
affirmation we're getting from all of
these people who don't actually even
know us
how do you go from working on
evolutionary psychology to mindfulness
to politics and the end of the world
i don't know they seem closely
interconnected in my mind at least uh
well as for evolutionary psychology and
mindfulness
uh that's actually kind of
straightforward i think i mean it
you know i i my view
of buddhism or at least of kind of
buddhist meditative practice and kind of
the buddhist
prescription for dealing with a human
predicament
is that it's actually a pretty smart
response to
the problem posed by human nature to the
way we naturally view things
process information feel things and
human nature is a product of evolution i
mean evolutionary psychology is about
human nature
so um you know for example
uh mindfulness can deal with anxiety and
and
and so the question arises is why is
there anxiety to begin with and
the answer seems to be uh we're
engineered by natural selection to feel
it under certain circumstances
uh but that doesn't mean that it's
always
good for us uh and
mindfulness gives us a way of dealing
with anxiety and a number of other
kind of problems with being human uh
the end of the world stuff i mean you're
right like my latest obsession is this
thing i call the apocalypse aversion
project
um that's long been a concern of mine
it's certainly related to human nature
uh in the in the sense that i think uh
our evolved psychology
is uh in some ways an obstacle
to forming the kind of global community
i think we need to form to solve the
world's problems
before they get out of hand and i'm
specifically thinking of what is
sometimes
called the the psychology of tribalism
that is those parts of our evolved
psychology that can lead us into
pointless and counterproductive
arguments and hostilities
uh these this psychology tends to
involve cognitive biases and
and you might say a kind of warped
perception of the world
uh and so you know if if that indeed
uh if if this psychology is one thing
standing in the way of um
solving the world's problems then you
can see how mindfulness comes back into
the picture it might
help us get our minds in a position
where we're
we're better equipped to uh to help the
civilization survive so avoiding the
apocalypse
is that a global coordination problem is
that an individual responsibility
i would say it's both i mean you know
the uh
i uh wrote a book a while ago called
non-zero
uh that was a reference to game theory a
non-zero sum problem
is uh is a problem where or a game a
non-zero-sum game is a game where
there can be a win-win or a lose-lose
outcome doesn't have to be a win-lose
uh outcome and one thing i said near the
end of that is that the world you know
more and more
uh nations face non-zero-sum
challenges that is to say uh problems
where they can both
come out ahead or many nations can
together come out ahead like avoiding
nuclear war
that's a good example nuclear weapons
create a radically non-zero sum
situation nuclear war would be bad for
everybody
uh and avoiding it is good for everybody
and i was just saying there are more and
more problems like this climate change
is one
uh various environmental problems like
overfishing the seas uh
various arms control problems uh
bioweapons
uh so on the one hand yes it's a
political
challenge that nations uh could
cooperate to address
but on the other hand uh there is a
dimension of individual psychology
because if you ask well why aren't
nations uh in some cases getting along
well enough
to cooperate uh sometimes at least i
think the answer is
you know the human psychology uh
it i wouldn't say it's necessarily kind
of the fault
of a bunch of individual uh americans
say that they're not on better terms
with various nations but it is true that
that individual psychology
makes us susceptible to politicians who
want to
manipulate us and make us feel more fear
of another nation than maybe is
warranted and
and things like that so yeah i see i see
it as as both an answer to that question
it's a it's a grassroots problem of
individual psychology and
and i'd like to think of ways to
get people more mobilized uh
to address the problem at the individual
level
with an eye to the the global goal
uh and one one asset in that regard i
mean one one way to get people
interested in this is that i do
think that uh addressing
the psychological obstacles to global
cooperation
uh is also a way to become a happier
person i i think you know these are it
we're not i you know i don't think
we're made happy when we are
um you know whipped up into a state of
like tribalistic
uh frenzy you know and and and go on
social media
and find people to hate i mean uh
there is a sense in which that must be
gratifying or we wouldn't do it
maybe but uh i think in the long run um
you know we can be happier and more
deeply happy if we avoid some of these
pitfalls
so what is good for humanity in the
civilization-wide potential of us as a
species
is also enjoyable in the process of
getting to it for the individual agents
as well
i really think so i mean i i really
think that
that if you just uh you know follow
uh mindfulness uh for the purpose
of kind of therapy to become a little
less
anxious maybe a little more stable a
little more appreciative of the beauty
in the world and of other people
i think you will wind up becoming a
better citizen
and uh you know without even trying
necessarily i just think
uh it'll be harder for politicians to
whip you up into a state of hatred
uh you'll be a little less inclined
to fall for bait on social media
and uh and contribute to
uh kind of the tribalism problem by
sharing things retweeting things without
really examining
uh the consequences of that so yeah i
i do think that's the good news that uh
you know self-help and kind of helping
the world can
coincide yeah i mean stepping into that
mindfulness gap
if you've spent a bit of time doing
meditation one of the coolest things
is observing an emotion arise inside of
you and sometimes they're
negative emotions right and sometimes
they're triggered by some
idiot on the other side of the internet
and sometimes the idiot is you for
watching something that you know that
you shouldn't have watched or reading
something you know you shouldn't have
read
um but yeah it's it's everything can be
a meditative exercise
in that regard yeah absolutely um
and i encourage people you know people
think of
mindfulness some people do as as
you know something that uh happens
during meditation or at least that you
have to meditate uh rigorously
to cultivate and i do encourage
people to try meditation um and to keep
meditating but
you can also just try to be mindful even
if you've never meditated
uh in various ways uh you can for
example
if you're feeling sad would rather not
feel sad
um uh or at least would not rather not
suffer
from sadness uh just sit down close your
eyes
and examine the feeling just ask
yourself like where exactly in my head
and body is the feeling of sadness and
just examine the contours
and you'll probably find that some of
the suffering has gone out of it in in
the process of you're examining it
and i would also encourage people to
experiment on social media even if
they've never meditated just
next time you you're about to retweet
something
or about to reply to somebody who annoys
you
or about to do anything on social media
just like stop
and close your eyes and examine the
feeling you're feeling
that is motivating you to do that you
know
we do things because of feelings
feelings are the great motivators
thoughts are involved in the process but
generally speaking
when we are motivated to do something
there is
a feeling however subtle driving us to
do that and
um i'd encourage people yeah on social
media just
at any point in life just stop close
your eyes examine the feeling it's just
kind of interesting
uh whatever feeling good bad uh
whatever it's just good practice and
sometimes it can keep you out of trouble
one of the things i've been thinking
about a lot recently is whether or not
another alien civilization could be any
more emotional
than we are or quick to emotion and one
of the things that
i've come to believe is they couldn't be
because if you were to turn up our
emotionality by
10 or 20 i think that coordination would
be so difficult that you wouldn't
actually be able to achieve very much
so given the fact that we're trying to
avert an apocalypse
we're hopefully going to fulfill our
civilizational potential and become
multi-planetary space-faring
you know type 3 kardashev civilizations
is there a potential that our emotional
set point
is a glass ceiling which it's a sicilian
task to try and get past with regards to
mindfulness you would need everybody to
be dedicating 10
000 of their life simply to be able to
get to the point where we could
coordinate sufficiently well
to reach our potential are we too
emotional to be the civilization that we
want to be
well it's a great opportunity to plug my
newsletter uh
the non-zero newsletter because the the
links in the show notes below link in
show notes below
the the issue i sent out last night uh
i think this one went out only to only
to paid subscribers but
uh the uh was about ufos and and
and uh because you know they've gotten a
lot of attention lately the us
government's gonna publish its big
report on ufos within a few weeks
apparently and there was a big 16
minutes on them
and i made the argument that
uh you shouldn't worry
uh that they may be extraterrestrial i
mean i have no idea if they are not i'm
not like a ufo guy but
uh but uh you shouldn't worry that oh no
maybe they're extraterrestrials
uh in fact in a certain sense you should
hope that they are and
the reasoning i gave is is is i think
pretty aligned if i understand you
correctly what you're saying i mean i i
said
uh well this this
could use a little background maybe you
you may have heard of the fermi p
paradox the idea that you know wait a
second
in principle there are so many planets
out there that could have life
if you ask just in our galaxy the milky
way galaxy
which is one of a jillion galaxies how
many planets are those that seem to be
in the goldilocks zone that is neither
too hot nor too cold for life
the current estimate is like 20 billion
or something okay
or more probably more and so
if you assume that well on some of you
know that
so probably a lot of them you know fair
number of those probably have water and
so
if if life is the kind of thing that
arises when circumstances are conducive
given long enough and by the way a lot
of these planets are way older than ours
so there's been a lot of time
if you assume that life kind of tends to
start and that evolution has a decent
chance
at least of producing intelligent life
and that intelligent life tends to
launch technological evolution
you know pretty soon you find yourself
asking well
why haven't we been contacted by aliens
because you'd think
there would be some out there that are
like millennia ahead of us in terms of
technological evolution
and so challenging as it is to
communicate
from another solar system uh or even
travel from another solar system
you'd think there would be something to
solve the problem and so on so so that's
the fermi paradox
and you know if there's so many
opportunities uh
for an advanced civilization to develop
in our galaxy and and the universe more
broadly
why haven't we heard from that's the
paradox and one answer you get is well
maybe
when uh civilizations get to our level
that is they have the technology that
they could use to bind
themselves into a into a into a
planetary community
solve any problems they need to solve or
they could blow the whole thing up
maybe they blow the whole thing up
that's a that's a common answer to the
question
uh posed by the fermi paradox and so i
said two things first of all
uh you might hope that there are
extraterrestrials showing up
just so that you'll know like it's
doable i mean
they've got past the great filter
therefore so it's impossible to get past
this
this so-called uh this one variant of
the so-called great filter
the other the other thing i said is i
would guess
that if they did get past the great
filter
they're probably morally enlightened
enough that they're not going to just
like torture us or eat us right
i mean like like uh because
you know again my view is that if planet
earth is going to get
past uh the current
crossroads then people broadly are going
to have to really make
in a certain sense more moral progress
they're gonna have to overcome some of
their
tendency to be just gratuitously and
harshly judgmental of other people and
kind of come up
with reasons to hate other groups and
stuff
and uh so you know i i think
um i i think if there's a if there's a
civilization that's gotten beyond
this threshold that we are maybe stuck
at
and surmounted the challenge uh
i would suspect that they're probably
um you know closer to moral
enlightenment
than we are and not inclined to
gratuitously inflict
uh suffering on other sentient beings
that would be my guess
well that actually rolls forward from my
proposal
my proposal is that most civilizations
couldn't be more emotional
than us because they would struggle with
global coordination
if i'm saying that i think we're
somewhere near the ceiling of that
you have to presume that well i don't
know if less emotionality would be akin
to
more enlightenment i'm not really too
sure about that i don't know how those
two map on to each other
but they they shouldn't be at least more
tribal than us
or else how the [ __ ] have they managed
to colonize the galaxy and get
or get over here at the very least they
would have to be less
tribal i think i mean you can imagine
scenarios where they
they uh they they consolidate planetary
order without becoming less tribal it
seems to me unlike totalitarianism
perhaps or some sort of yeah
yeah democracy overlord yeah it tends to
be an unstable thing
the um i i think i i mean as for whether
you're talking about kind of a
level of emotionality uh
in a certain sense i would agree i mean
i i would i would say when you become
mindful
yes there's a sense in which you're
becoming less emotional but you know
people mindfulness practitioners and
teachers
want to be very careful with the
language here it's not like your
feelings are going away
it's that you are less slavishly
obedient to don't identify with them
right you you you're better at not
identifying with them when it's not your
interest to do that
and um so i i think
if you appreciate the if you presume
that the emotionality being higher made
not identifying with the more difficult
though
that should end up but yeah similar sort
of
imagine just subduing the emotions uh
and that having somewhat the same effect
i'm i'm just saying it's not exactly i
think i understand
it's not exactly the same as uh
mindfulness
um you know
it's uh of course the the you know the
the little thing i just said about the
fermi paradox and my take on it there
are all kinds of
assumptions underlying my analysis
and and some of them are are hard to
to kind of get a grip on um like you
know
well would any species and it would any
technologically advanced species
be prone to tribalism in the first place
in other words would that be something
it had to overcome
i think you could argue there are
reasons to think maybe so
given given the way natural selection
works i think there are reasons to think
maybe so but
but i would just acknowledge that that's
an example of something
i'm kind of assuming without really
examining
yeah i think i'm not sure obviously the
next couple of months are potentially
going to be
some of the most revelatory in human
history it depending on what gets
released
from these files but to me it seems
unlikely that they're
living beings unless they've got some
underwater station perhaps
but what would make most sense would
probably be
i mean what do you do when you've got in
the antarctic
and you're just doing observations
observation posts tend to have some sort
of technological component
that's able to do the observation on
your behalf you have cameras you have
sensors you have so on and so forth
you know why not just make a base down
at the bottom of the
the seabed it's far less likely the fish
aren't going to bother you
perhaps you're able to capture some sort
of geothermal energy that can keep you
ticking over
or based on what these tic tac videos
are showing it looks like you probably
don't even need that you can just bend
space time around you so
who needs energy um yeah it's an
interesting one it's
it's going to be a a fascinating period
but i mean god this
kind of if it's not something
from earth there's so many fields that
get up ended
a little bit yeah it would be pretty
freaky
uh i i mean the you know the report has
been leaked
to the new york times or at least
selectively the the officials who leaked
it wanted to get some messages out and
what what the new york times said is
they don't
find strong evidence that these are
extraterrestrials on the other hand
they are puzzled uh by the properties
that some of these apparent if these are
indeed flying objects uh they are
uh they seem to possess capabilities
that
we don't have and uh
you know i i honestly don't know i'll be
curious to look at the report
itself but uh you know as for the
question you ask i mean there's a couple
of things first of all you might say
well given the fact that a civilization
would presumably develop the capacity to
communicate with us from a distance
before it would develop the capacity to
actually get here
which isn't an easy thing to do from
like 10 000 light years away
um then uh although some
some solar systems are much closer than
that uh but uh
uh wouldn't you expect that that would
be the first sign that you you'd be
getting these radio waves that's one
question
you know the other question maybe more
closely related the one you ask
is uh you know these there's kind of a
couple of
a pretty interesting uh sightings that
i'm aware of the
the most interesting seem to be the on
the one hand the
eyewitness testimony of this david
fravor guy the pilot off of san diego
because there were three eyewitnesses
in two planes right i mean there was uh
uh
one of his uh uh uh
the uh there was a woman who was a fight
who was flying the plane above him
and she so she watched what he did from
uh from a distance
he meanwhile went down and engaged what
he says was an
aircraft and so and you've got two
people in each plane
and and for the first time i'm aware we
actually heard from this woman on 16
minutes the other day so
so that seems to be intrinsically
interesting when you listen to their
uh testimony um and there are
kind of remote kinds of corroboration of
that i mean there was uh they were
originally dispatched there by a
uh a cruiser uh i think it was a cruiser
navy ship
uh that uh had seen these things on its
radar that wanted to investigate and
then uh
but they did not get anything on camera
from their plane during that
sighting a plane came later that day i
think a plane went out and saw something
that might be something and that's the
the flare video
uh uh you know infrared video the the
other interesting sighting is is
apparently apparently these things just
persisted
for months in like uh the one i just
described is 2004. these other ones were
like i think around 2014
and uh they were off the east coast of
the united states and um
uh they're they're those are the videos
where it's like
people are going whoa you know and the
uh
those are two other videos and um so
i've asked myself
looking at those like okay so suppose
these are extraterrestrials i've asked
myself the question you've asked like
well first of all why are they exposing
themselves like this
and i guess one
thought could be like they didn't
realize they were that visible because
the navy never released the videos you
know i
i don't know i mean uh but it is
it is puzzling and it may be reason uh
to think there's less here than meets
the eye i don't know but
um i don't uh i mean maybe that's a
better answer to the san diego one
because there was only one siding
that that that that craft seemed to have
the ability to
maybe even submerge in the in the ocean
uh
at a minimum hover above it uh and
uh and that's the only sighting of that
kind so maybe that's a case where like
okay it got seen once and then it's like
then they change their program right
like
i don't know it's it's fun to speculate
about this stuff but i don't have you
have you gotten very deeply into this
stuff
i've watched the joe rogan episodes with
commander david fraver
and i've seen a bunch of other videos on
the internet and i mean joe's
balls deep in this stuff so he's a
actually a pretty good sort of one-stop
shop
in terms of a resource for it but yeah
you're right it's a very unceremonious
if this is
aliens it's like the least ceremonial
way that you no
no landing on the white house lawn just
right
[ __ ] about in the pacific in the
atlantic ocean
yeah and you would think if they're
advanced enough to get here i mean we're
talking about advanced technology if
they could get here from another solar
system
you would think you would think that it
wouldn't take them
terribly long to decode our
communication and be able to communicate
with us
and at that point like why wouldn't they
i guess if they think of us as this
interesting experiment
um they just want to watch i don't know
but uh you know
it's it's i you know i've walked watch
debunking videos and i am totally
agnostic
on the question of whether there's any
anything here at all
i just i just don't know it's just that
it's fun to speculate
uh and when you hear some of these
people like fravor and that other pilot
talk together you think
pretty weird and it's so it's compelling
because you have these multiple
viewpoints mark
yeah it's an interesting one man going
back to what you were talking about at
the beginning which is this relationship
between
evolutionary psychology and mindfulness
or buddhism
is how much of a place is there for an
evolutionary psychology insight from the
individual
if they are a mindfulness practitioner
or just if they want to live a
peaceful life because i have my biases
with regards to
this particular world view but what are
your thoughts
you mean the world view of evolutionary
psychology or the fact that
in my opinion mindfulness without an
insight into evolutionary psychology
at least a shallow one and a little bit
of an understanding of how cognitive
biases work
i don't think that you're getting the
full picture because for me
i want to ask the question why
right why is it like that why does this
affect me in this way and that's when
you need the adaptive explanation
right um you know obviously
uh for centuries and centuries and
centuries
uh meditators have gotten something out
of meditation
including mindfulness meditation um
without having evolutionary psychology
since it you know we've only known about
natural selection
for uh about a century and a half um
the uh so so it can have benefits and
and it can have profound ones there
there are people who
uh i'm sure have gotten to great great
depths greater depths than i've gotten
to
uh who lived centuries ago
and got there via mindfulness meditation
at the same time i have found since
writing my book about
buddhism why buddhism is true that
a number of people respond uh
by saying it is helpful to their
practice
to understand where these feelings come
from in the first place like
why they're here why do humans
have anxiety why why uh
to to look at a more generic problem
that's that's confronted head-on by
buddhism
why are we so hard to satisfy why is it
that you know
you have that one donut you wait a while
you want another one you know
it's like whatever it is that next
promotion
the the the latest material acquisition
your new gimmick that brings you
gratification for a few days
sex whatever gratification
tends to be fleeting and this is you
know
this is just the fundamental problem
that buddhism uh confronted
from the get-go uh the fact that we seem
to be driven by these
thirsts they they uh can never
be satisfied for very long in fact you
know
um the uh the term dukkha you know
the famous phrase life is suffering
which actually the buddha never quite
exactly said in so many words but anyway
he did say life is
uh pretty full of suffering uh and the
word that's translated to suffering is
dukkha and some people think you could
also
translate that as unsatisfactoriness
that or that in any event it has
it would have had that connotation in in
the buddhist day that
the problem with life is that we
keep wanting more right we we there's
always this restless feeling uh of
more and i don't plan to ever uh
completely prevail over that i don't
even really want to
i mean you know it's not you need a
motivating force right
yeah yeah it's not a horrible affliction
in itself
but it really does uh
get out of control more often than i'd
like and
you know you're just you're better off
uh i mean even
you know if you have this motivator of
wanting
more in just in the sense of more
influence i mean say you're in
like kind of my line of work or years
you're a podcaster you're right or
whatever
you would like to have more influence on
people you like to think that you're
trying to influence them in a positive
way
and you'd like to do more of that okay
so fine um
but even uh that goal i think you can
pursue more effectively if in a lot of
realms
you'll let go of the desire for more i
mean just just to take uh a very simple
example like uh i have you know
uh what i think it's fair to call
attention deficit disorder i have a lot
of
trouble focusing and if you examine
what's going on there in a kind of a
mindful way
you realize that it's a quest for
pleasure right it's like i'm i'm trying
to write an email or write something
i get a little stuck i don't know what
to write next
and that causes an unpleasant feeling
it's like uh
i don't know what to do and then you
think like
wouldn't it be fun to research like your
next smartphone purchase or something
yeah that would be a lot more fun i
enjoy doing that
and that's just a click away right and
and when i examine what keeps me from
being able to focus on things
it is this constant desire to be
uh to get a little more pleasure and and
have a little less discomfort
and that leads you to not confront
things that need confronting and if you
can discipline yourself this isn't easy
but if you can get yourself
when you feel that desire to like uh
go open another tab or go downstairs and
watch tv watch sports or something uh
if you can just close your eyes and
examine the feeling
that's making you want to do that uh you
know you can
you can get better at uh well some
people would complain
if i say resisting it uh some
mindfulness aficionados but in any event
not being
uh kind of governed by it
um so i'm not i'm not i'm not
you know looking for an all-out assault
on
our quest for pleasure or achievement or
accomplishment or anything
uh i'm i'm just at least in my own case
trying to pursue my goals more
effectively
uh in a way and as it happens i think
pursuing them more effectively
makes you happier as well i think this
point about the duka bias
uh comes to one of the most central
questions that most people
in the 21st century are asking because
we are
objective metrics of success we are
meritocracy
materialist reductionist utilitarian
and when you combine all of that
together with the status hierarchies
that are built in and where am i and
what do i want next and hedonic
treadmill all this sort of stuff
the inevitable unsatisfactoriness of
most of the experiences in life
can cause you to continue to chase
things
in a desperate attempt to try and fill
that hole coming from a scarcity mindset
that you're running away from
insufficiency as opposed to running
toward abundance
and that is the number of conversations
that i've had
about that map
of experience is huge
because for most people for many people
especially with social media now which
is an objective
quantifiable metric of your social
status might be a rough
or a shitty one but um yeah
with all of this combined and weaponized
and utilized and monetized it's a
difficult situation to be in to be a
happy peaceful balanced human
yeah now that's a good example of
i think how how evolutionary psychology
figures into this i mean you know the
quest
for esteem the quest to be respected
is the most natural thing in the world
for human beings
we are designed by natural selection to
want people to think highly of us
but we weren't designed to live in this
environment
where uh you know we are
every day uh seeing how
uh how much affirmation we're getting
from all of these people
who don't actually even know us right
i mean you know you you
it's like it is genuinely painful
to tweet something that leads a bunch of
people to judge you negatively
and they're like in no position to judge
you
you know it's crazy when you think about
it
and yet uh and yet here we are
and it's it's another case where if you
can just pause
and examine the actual feeling of pain
like
this is hurting me just reflect on the
feeling
i think the feeling will be a little
less
uh painful and but at the same time the
the the desire the the uh you know when
you tweet something and you're like
ah let's check every five seconds to see
how many likes i have or retweets
you know that feeling too i think
warrants um
reflecting on because it can become
pathological it's it's and and and you
know this is
to get back to psychology of tribalism
this is a big problem for our society at
large because
twitter you know social media tends to
reward
tribalistic behavior the easiest way in
the world to build up your twitter
following
is to find a a pretty big group
trump supporters trump haters whatever
and just reinforce the prejudices right
just like
oh like whoever was this genius thing
the other day
claiming that trump had his pants on
backwards which turned out not to be
true but
didn't but somebody had you know whoever
whoever the person is who came up with
that picture
seeming to show that hey my hat's off to
you you really know how to play the
twitter game man just come up with total
[ __ ]
that is deeply gratifying to everyone
who hates donald trump and there's a lot
of those
and get it out there you know and
and then of course the effect of that is
for trump supporters to say see they do
nothing but lie about us
right the the trump the trump haters do
nothing but lie about us
and about trump that's all the more
reason not to trust the media
so if the media tells you the election
wasn't stolen don't believe them
and and it's just uh you know it's a
it's a it's a really deep problem
i mean i i i think somebody needs to
find a way
to make it be considered cool to not be
an [ __ ] on twitter
well the problem is no one knows no one
notices you when you're being silent
right reasonable people very rarely make
the headlines
no one says look at this incredibly
well-balanced nuanced centrist point
that was just made here
no one gives a [ __ ] and also a point
that i realized about sam harris
toward the back end of last year by
being in the middle you can guarantee
disagreement from both sides
at least when you're out on the extremes
you get agreement from one of them but
by sitting in the middle
and the stupid thing is that your view
on gun control should in no way be
influenced by your view on abortion or
your view
on the federal tax level or your view on
immigration or anything else
but because of the way that people have
become tribalized and because of how
politics
works that you tend to have this
two-party system at least in america
you get that so people get bunched
together in groups but very
there's no reason if i know one of your
views and from it i can accurately
predict everything else that you believe
i can probably safely assume that you're
not a serious thinker
right but but what the what political
polarization does is make it more and
more true that that's the case
because people choose their policy
preferences
by whatever the other side doesn't like
i mean
a kind a a a version of this kind of is
the way so many democrats in america are
suddenly
these anti-russia cold warriors it used
to be kind of reversed you know
and then the the idea developed that
russia had helped trump in the election
and i i personally think it turned out
to be a little
a little less there than met the eye i
mean the mueller gate investigation
didn't really
turn up all that much i mean russia did
try to intervene and help him where they
could and actually the email hack i
think was genuinely
consequential but the idea of floating
around in the resistance for a while was
like
oh he's there he's there uh you know
their mancurian candidate
that he did a deal with them and and
he's in bed with putin
and blah blah blah and that that led
all these democrats to suddenly uh
be like the cold warriors that
republicans used to be
and and there was just a complete flip
on that and and then republicans started
saying hey russia what's so bad with
russia
it's uh it's it's not a rational uh
process political polarization well look
at the positions on free speech now
that the people who are calling for
restrictions in free speech
traditionally would have been the ones
that were calling for
free speech absolutism right
uh no that's that's absolutely true
the uh you know when
when trump is thought to be the problem
then a lot of liberals are are in favor
of
uh him and his uh people like him being
shut down by
social media companies uh and i gotta
say life is a lot easier without him on
twitter
but but you know i would have been very
interested
to see if we could have mustered the
discipline i think if he hadn't been
kicked off twitter
there would have been a movement i
certainly would have supported it i
think he would have
heard it would have made some noise to
just ignore him
to just like start he's no longer
president
don't do him the favor of retweeting
anything he does
just ignore him i would have been
curious to see if we could muster
that much uh self-discipline i'm sure it
wouldn't have been a complete success
but
i i i'd like to know and and i guess we
won't know because i think he's banned
uh
from twitter for two years on facebook i
think it just
it's at least it's at least january 2023
on facebook but i think
twitter sounds like they have no plans
to ever reinstate him
i don't know yeah well i mean the news
is a lot more boring
without him being around hey i'm okay
with boring news yeah no i'm not i mean
i'm very ambivalent
about uh
the social media companies uh
shutting him down and in general i mean
like
well just there uh you know
i i don't think they're doing a great
job of of handling
uh the challenge and and i think they
should err on the side of
openness and have clear rules uh
but it's a weird i i kind of feel their
pain i mean if i were running twitter or
facebook and saw
how you know
untrue and dangerous things can spread
uh
rapidly and and and saw that we
had a president who you know was
inclined to say things that weren't
exactly thoroughly corroborated
uh and get them spread widely i i i
understand their temptation to do
something it's a tough
it's not easy i think the problem that
people have is that it appears like the
rules are being applied
discriminately right between the picking
particular actors or particular
viewpoints or particular political
positions
uh and both sides of the aisle consider
it to be their side which is the one
that's being maligned
right it's the if you have someone that
is in their left echo chamber they will
only be served
people on the left who have been
cancelled or had their channels removed
and everyone's up in arms about it
but if you're on the right-hand side of
the aisle you you don't see that at all
you just see your side
of people that have been cancelled and
have been removed yeah i mean here's
another thing do you remember when
the first big facebook uh
congress was in front of congress where
he had to give a statement where
zuckerberg had to give a statement and
it was that photo of him and everyone
accused him of being an android remember
this maybe about three or four years ago
he is an amazing looking guy i gotta say
he's a very android looking human um
but think about that look at jack dorsey
i mean jack dorsey just looks like a man
that's done far too many psychedelics
which very well may be the truth
but these are people especially
zuck right he was just a kid that
started a thing
and now he's strapped to this nuclear
warhead rocket going at a million miles
an hour
and you just look at him and you think
you just wanted you just wanted to do
like a cool thing on the internet and
as people progress on we go through life
we leave our old epochs behind we find
our new ones
but gods i don't know i i really do
wonder in his
darker moments or his more mindful
moments whether he thinks would life
have just been easier if i'd
started a shopify store or something and
was just doing ecom
yeah i i don't have a very clear sense
for what the answer to that is because
he's so hard to figure
i think it's because he's an android bob
well honestly i mean
i don't think he's andrew but i mean he
he does
seem not uh constrained by certain basic
human feelings i mean like you know when
he went to
uh like when he went to harvard you know
he started that site hot it was a hot or
not site
you know the one where uh so they're
comparing two different people
people who i guess were in the freshman
book or whatever at harvard
and people would vote on how attractive
they were now if i had that idea i'd
think
like i don't want to cause pain to these
people who are gonna get down voted
it's like this isn't cool he's
he doesn't have feelings like that and
he has treated facebook that way he's
just like
i do think he kind of sees us as
laboratory rats i mean
they've literally done experiments uh on
you know where they uh i forget the
details but where they just uh
they're like let's throw this out here
uh
and uh and see how people respond and i
forget i forget the details but there
are some
really controversial examples of that um
so i don't know i don't want to get off
on mark zuckerberg but
uh i'm trying to think are there any of
these companies that are in the hands of
people who seem like
deeply conscientious hard to say uh
but there is a lot of power in in a
small number of hands now because of the
way these companies you know
google facebook twitter just blow up and
dominate just by virtue of their
internal dynamics you don't
you don't have to be a ruthless
monopolist to make that happen
that just the positive network
externalities make these
platforms dominant and then you're right
suddenly you're running a dominant
platform the matthew principle is a hell
of a drug man
yeah yeah it really is um just
finishing off that duke bias thing that
we were talking about so there's another
side of the coin
i think that when people achieved
something that they thought was going to
give them pleasure
uh my favorite example is talking about
a holiday so you're planning a holiday
for ages you're all excited you know the
restaurant you know the table
you might even have looked at the menu
and know what you're going to order and
then you sit down but
then you notice that the sand between
your toes and maybe it should have been
iced instead of shaking
and i wish i'd gone for medium well
instead of medium rare
um that is a feature not a bug right
that's that's part of the source code
it's
in built into the substrate of our
existence that everything's just going
to be a little bit
more tarnished than you probably thought
or if it isn't it's going to be briefer
um what practices have you found
to allow yourself to be able to relish
those sort of
good moments a little bit more well
first of all as for the feature
bug thing before i answer your actual
question i mean that that i think is
interesting to delve into
a little because i think you're right
the the uh
the constant evaluation of these things
like couldn't this be a little bit
better it's not quite as good as i'd
expected
that is it is built in
and the reason it's built in is because
it's a feature
by the lights of natural selection okay
that
that is to say that apparently in our
species
and i think this would be true of a lot
of species but uh animals
uh that had that uh did a better job of
getting
uh their genes into the next generation
than other animals
but that doesn't mean it was ever a
feature
in terms of uh the happiness of the
individuals because natural selection
doesn't care about our happiness to
begin with
so it could be a feature from natural
selection's point of view
and a bug from the point of view of
human psychology and human happiness
from the beginning
and then there's the second sense in
which things can become bugs
and that's by virtue of how different
the environment we're in
is from uh the environment we were
designed for so for example um
the desire to feel a little better well
in an environment where there's cocaine
that can become a huge bug right you
know
and and and cocaine wasn't part of the
natural environment so so it wasn't
it wasn't a bug of that kind
um in uh in the environment of our
evolution so anyway that's just a little
just wanted to be clear on on kind of
the feature
bug thing i mean as for so you're asking
now about like
uh the uh
um i mean i'm first of all a little
blessed well there are senses in which
i'm very fuzz
fussy and senses in which i'm not and
i'm not like a foodie
you know it's like my wife's family
they're foodies
and and they're they're you know so
we'll we'll be eating and they'll be
commenting on whether something is you
know
above or below their expectations and
i'm like oh grub good
put in mouth chew swallow
go do something else uh fine
um so but uh
but but i definitely uh
have the problem at some level and
certainly one way
what do you have a weakness for if it's
not food what are some of the things
where
your dukabias raises its head
oh well
i mean first of all i'm very fussy about
like writing and stuff that can be
productive
uh like couldn't this be a little better
couldn't this sentence be a little
better
that can make your writing better um
i uh but i'm just i mean this will seem
at odds with what i just said i'm very
aware
of uh
i'm very self-conscious in the sense of
being aware of how
how i'm feeling at the time and and i
think that's uh
well i mean the the the worst form of
that is something i already alluded to
is just making it hard to concentrate
because i do
find myself thinking uh
um you know wouldn't i feel better if i
had a little more coffee
or a little more chocolate or something
of this
i mean that may seem at odds with what i
just said about food but
my point is i'm not like a connoisseur
it's like i
it's like what i naturally do is just
think about
the psychological effect of food so like
i'm aware that uh carbohydrates will
sedate me so i will i will
i will eat them for that purpose you
know
um and i could probably stand to be a
little less conscious at that level of
how everything is
is influencing me um
[Music]
but uh i don't know i mean i mean
things i'm things that i find
temptations i find it very easy to
succumb to are like watching sports on
tv
that's not a horrible thing but carried
too far
can lead you to never accomplish
anything again for the rest of your life
uh yeah what um
i don't know i i yeah so just think
about what about reveling
in things end states events
achievements just allowing those to
linger a little bit longer
it feels like that's something that i
think a lot of people wish
the holiday that they're planning to go
on the new house that they're planning
to buy even
someone that's taken the hedonic
treadmill red pill and
knows that look this isn't going to be
an inherent source of happiness but it's
still something that i can be proud of
in what it symbolically represents that
i have worked for this that it is a new
stage a new level that i've reached
within my life
whatever it might be um you're just not
looking for that next thing it seems
like that balance
again delivered by culture delivered by
evolutionary psychology
both kind of colliding and combining and
increasing um that just seems to be one
of the challenges that people have and i
think one of the reasons they get into
mindfulness
to avoid negative emotions and to
further allow themselves to enjoy
positive ones and
uh yeah i mean i i think
the trick is partly not to have too much
of a grasping
kind of attitude toward
the feeling of success uh
i don't know i sometimes wonder you know
these uh
like right now i'm wondering like how is
phil mickelson feeling like i don't know
if you follow golf
but he just became the uh oldest person
ever to win a major golf tournament he
he was a month away from 51. this was a
couple of weeks ago
and he had been working just incredibly
hard
to get back in the in the game even
though he's passed way past his prime
and uh i wondered how long does the
thrill
uh last and and and how you know
uh for him uh i mean
i i don't know i think it's certainly
true that a lot of people
who have accomplished great things are
not very happy precisely because the
feeling always evaporates
and and and that's what keeps them
motivated
uh but
i know in my case i am confident
that uh i could by becoming
more mindful and i think i've already
made some progress in that regard
um actually become more productive uh
you know because uh you know i think
there is some
level of uh mindfulness you could get to
where you were uh
you know you were less ambitious that
that can happen you know people it's a
common question people say
uh if i what if i meditate so much that
um i just no longer have the desire to
succeed or whatever
uh and i say well first of all by
definition you'll probably
be happy that's why you know you'll let
go of it but also
it's almost certainly not going to
happen i mean uh it i think for most of
us
uh you know just
getting uh too too mindful enough
to pursue the goals we most care about
more effectively is enough of a
challenge and the chances of getting so
far beyond that point that we just sit
around meditate all day
is pretty slim it's the same argument
that i give to
girls who are worried that lifting
weights in the gym is going to make them
too muscly
that you know how long and how hard
i've worked in the gym in a desperate
attempt to become muscly
and you're concerned that by lifting the
sixes instead of the fours
that you're going to walk out if they're
jacked out of your mind so this isn't
going to happen
overshooting with things like this
especially where people dedicate a lot
of time to it
it's just so unlikely and there's so
much work to be done to get to that
point that
it's not as if it's going to come out of
nowhere you're not just going to wake up
one day
and your default mode network's just
completely shut off or you've got 23 in
charms
right it's like get back to me if this
becomes a problem like
if you're just sitting around in a state
of bliss all day
i'll have two questions is it really a
problem if you're in a state of bliss
all day a
and b did this really happen because i
don't think it's gonna happen
um but uh so you're you're like us
you're like a serious fitness guy right
i train a lot yes and and is this uh
do you have trouble staying motivated
sometimes sometimes yeah yeah
and it's like what weightlifting and
what is it a combination so
sometimes it's crossfit sometimes it's
bodybuilding um
the reason that motivation sometimes
ebbs and flows is that one training
methodology often gets boring
but you can easily change that up going
to muay thai so i went out to thailand
and
i'm going to go to more functional
fitness so i'm going to start doing yoga
for a while and now i'm back into
bodybuilding again and
so on and so forth yeah
no that makes sense uh i kind of feel
that way about different meditation
techniques sometimes you know you start
seeming to get diminishing returns and
there are different things you can try
different techniques
i've really found that recently i was
with shinzen young's
five ways to know yourself so i was
following that for
the longest time and um
it just after a while it just felt like
banging your head off a wall
and i can't remember where i heard it
someone's
used this analogy they said don't expect
the boat that carried you across the
river to take you across land to the
next river
and that was a really nice insight like
look
you've made some gains leave it there
right
let's look forward what can there be
what have been some of the major pivots
that you've made that have helped your
mindfulness practice
uh well you know it goes up and down
um a thing i'm trying now
because i have hit uh you know kind of a
wall
um is
just meditating a second time a day um
the uh you know because i i do meditate
every morning
and that's that's good uh
but you know later in the day you'll
have a
there's there's uh there's different
stuff to meditate on
like you may by by 5 00
p.m um your mind is just in a different
place
there's probably a little more
restlessness uh
some aggravations and
what i've just started doing like
yesterday is realizing that look as long
as you're wearing a fitness watch you
can just set it
to go off every day at 6 30 pm and
uh it's a reminder to meditate because
all other
uh reminders in my life don't work
because like
the you know the the the because my
appointment calendar
always signals 15 minutes before an
appointment you just you just get in the
habit of dismissing that without even
thinking about it so
i finally had this epiphany yesterday
like set your watch and you'll only get
one alarm
you know i'll meditate in the morning
and then so uh
yesterday was the first day of doing
that i like it
you're definitely right in saying that
morning is i wouldn't say easy mode but
it's less hard mode
than later on in the day if you're
committing yourself to i have to
meditate every day and you miss your
morning session
the anxiety that you know it's gonna be
like i'm gonna sit down for 15 minutes
and i'm gonna have that song that i
heard in the car on the way to the gym
in my head and that conversation i've
just had with my business partner and so
on and so forth
yeah yeah i mean in a way later in the
day sometimes it's
easier in the sense that there is
something to meditate on
right like there is a specific
uh frustration or you're mad at somebody
or just at that moment you're feeling
some sharp emotion that's a result of
what happened that day
sometimes that's that's good to have a
to have uh
something in your body to focus on aside
from just the breath
as a new or fairly recent
sub stack convert yourself
what do you think we've learned over the
last sort of 12 months we've seen people
like matthew iglesias
decide to just leave his position at vox
which was
super prestigious probably incredibly
well paid and maybe
now making even more money there we've
seen scott alexander do the same go from
probably one of the biggest
if not the biggest rationalist blogs in
the world to
start astral codex 10 what's your
experience been coming at the
creator economy from this side um
[Music]
i had actually been on sub stack a while
uh and i only went paid
uh a few months ago
so i built up a pretty substantial email
list of people who are getting it for
free
and so now i'm in the process of doing
you know
uh you know certain amount of paid
content some free content and you try to
convert people from the
free list to the paid list that's a
basic um
strategy and i'm finding it uh
you know reasonably gratifying uh
i i it's not it it hasn't made me
uh wealthy beyond my wildest dreams by
any means
i don't you know i don't have the
optimal
uh kind of stick for it you know i mean
it's kind of like building up a big
following on twitter you're best off
uh if you can like
make like kind of incendiary arguments
and get a bunch of people
mad and make a bunch of other people
happy matt by the way matt iglesias
uh is is an interesting kind of
exception to that i mean he does make
some people angry
but he consistently puts out pretty
cerebral well
well thought out uh stuff and he's not
especially tribal he's a pretty
mild-mannered
dude i had him on the show and he seemed
like an incredibly mild-mannered dude
although his internet persona may be
different i haven't seen
enough to be able to comment on that
well he will tell you
uh that he has a temper
and he actually does i know him a little
uh but but it doesn't come out that
often
um and he's he's pretty good at rising
above
uh so i don't know i don't
i think there's going to be a limited
number of huge success stories
like him glenn greenwald matt tybee um
because partly i think people are
getting subscriber fatigue i mean
you know it's like you can only
subscribe to so many newsletters
actually pay for them
before you start thinking wait a second
like how much money can i spend on this
uh so i don't know
um i don't have a clear sense for the
landscape in terms of how many people
are making a huge success of it
uh and and um how many
aren't are you gonna see more creators
pay wall their content hide behind stuff
because people do this for different
reasons
some people do it stephen crowd is a
good example of this the reason that
stephen crowder pay walls some of his
content
is that he doesn't want that to be the
trending news story
he wants to say things within a world
community that he doesn't want
seen by the wider world or at least
shared to the wider world
uh other people want to do it to assist
them financially other people want to do
it for a whole litany of reasons
um is that the at least that makes
i i i can see the logic in fact i'm
doing kind of a version of that myself i
mean the way i'm so the newsletter is
called the non-zero newsletter
the thing the apocalypse aversion
project
is something that i think of as being
kind of the part that's behind
the paywall for the most part and
certainly one thing that's
uh behind the paywall uh is you know i'm
i'm kind of trying to put together a
conception of a book
on the subject of the apocalypse
aversion project whether it be called
that or not i don't know
but when i've uh when i've most
explicitly dealt with that like
here's a draft of an introduction to the
book or
here's the overall argument of the book
i've done that behind the paywall
and and i do uh
i do feel more comfortable doing that in
front of a
uh smaller and less judgmental audience
right i mean these are
you would think if they're paying for my
newsletter these are people who don't
hate me so they're probably not gonna
just kind of tear
into me and yet uh they will uh you know
i
ask for uh constructive feedback and and
they give it in the comments section and
that's
useful sometimes they email me um
and so that that is working for me
thinking of this not just as a revenue
generation thing
but also as a place where you can
cultivate a particular project
in an environment that's conducive to
that so you are able to use
the paywall as a selection effect to
find a particular group of people
who are bought in at a particular level
and then you're building in public
and permitting that particular group of
more brought in
probably deeper understanding of your
work
that community to then give you feedback
on it jack butcher from visualize value
is doing something incredibly similar
but on the graphics side he has this big
community and then
other people he's got a huge um slack
thing where all different people show
their work and then they all comment on
each other so he's almost got this
iterative process for the people that
are doing what he's doing within his
community as well so
i think that's a that's quite a cool
thing that you that you have going on
there i mean you see this with
uh locals locals which is dave rubin's
equivalent of patreon uh some center and
center-right people have kind of
taken to that platform because it's like
a facebook so you want
you have friends and you can have
conversations with other people
which means that the creator actually
passively creates content
just by having a group of followers that
all
communicate with themselves so yeah i
think it's a liberating
time it's just interesting to see what's
happening especially someone um
scott alexander and matt were two
examples i thought of because matt was
in such a prestigious position
i thought that would be the sort of
person that would maybe never leave
and scott was in a position that was
so uh
he was obviously doing his sight and
dramonica and he was kind of abstracted
away from it a little bit and wasn't a
public-facing guy
and for him to then turn on a dime i
know the new york times article had
something to do with that but
for him to switch that strategy i just
thought
those were two really like okay there's
something that really something to this
yeah well i think matt for one thing
wanted to feel a little more liberated
to write what he wanted
uh the um he was
when he was on my show on my uh the
right show he
explained this was a few months ago he
he
explained uh why he left uh
in a way that's more subtle than than
how i would characterize it
but i do think at least part of the uh
part of the dynamic was that vox uh
was getting pretty woke uh
which isn't necessarily a bad thing but
in some cases maybe made him feel
constraints you know he had signed the
uh
so-called harper's letter uh which is
kind of an
anti-anti-cancer culture letter it was
mostly conservatives but some
progressives like him and michelle
goldberg signed it
and he he got into some trouble for that
from some uh from i think a trans
vox staffer who said that because
the letter had also been signed by
somebody
that this person considered anti-trans
uh you know killed by assassins issue
what's that
yeah yeah whatever uh so
and this was before he left fox um i
don't know how much that had to do with
it but
uh you know it's certainly
a number of people have said uh
they go to um subsect for the freedom
um you know there are various places you
can go you can start a podcast
uh for the freedom uh
and it's true that if you you know i
i've
worked in olden times for you know a
number of actual publications and it's
true there's always some kind of
constraint there always was
i mean it wasn't always like it is now
uh but there were always things that
you know when you thought about it if
you wrote them they would not be welcome
at that publication you know
um there's no there's no freedom like
having your own platform
yeah uh yeah it's interesting especially
apple are rolling out
you may have seen a paid only
internal thing now so you can pay wall
content within the apple podcast app
itself spotify
if they haven't already rolled out it in
beta will almost certainly be doing it
that's the reason for getting rogan and
the obamas on and so on and so forth
because they want to build up the
listener base so that they can then say
look
we'll monetize we'll host through i
think they've got anchor fm or radio fm
or something
and we'll then be able to let you do
audience capture in terms of this
so yeah i mean for the people that have
things to say and an audience to say it
to it's a
it's a good time but look although
although spotify
you know i i think uh they got some
staff
blowback on rogan and i think they
didn't they even remove some things from
the archives or something
they didn't transfer across a bunch of
episodes and
then later reinstated
most but it seemed
very particular the ones that hadn't
been pushed across people that have been
cancelled people that
held views that were contrary to some of
the ones so
alex jones crystalia michaela peterson
sagan avocad
a couple of others but i think some of
them are eight years old
i mean in english an english cricketer
has just been
pulled from the cricket team
for two tweets that he sent nine years
ago when he was 18.
um and yeah so there is no
window of time apparently within which
you can uh
you can be liberated from that so yeah
you know rogan's old podcasts were just
as culpable i suppose
yeah well fortunately they didn't have
social media when i was 18.
that's one of the the things that i
absolutely adore i have a very spotty
record from uh from that age there's
not many not many witnesses who are
talking
i'm happy to say bob thank you very much
for coming on if people want to sign up
to the newsletter check out your stuff
why should they go
well they can on twitter i'm uh at
robert reiter w-r-i-g-h-t-e-r
uh there is the non-zero newsletter both
the paid
and the unpaid version i um my show the
right show
is actually part of uh it's kind of
complicated
uh there's two two uh
well now youtube channels originally
websites that i started one called
bloggingheads.tv one called meaning of
life.tv
all of my podcasts are on one or the
other of those but both of those
channels also have uh
other content on them and they are
podcast feeds
as well as being um like youtube
channels
and i think that's all that occurs to me
i i encourage buying my books of course
uh or just sending me cash just just
just fly over my house and drop cash
[Laughter]
thank you very much for today mate thank
you chris this was fun
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace
you